the secretary of state is back in the
region
to drum up support for normalization
deals between israel and some arab
states
increase pressure on iran and make some
headway in talks to end the blockade of
qatar
mike pompeo is due in doha and riyadh in
the days ahead
this says u.s catri and saudi officials
have signaled in recent weeks
that a breakthrough may be near on
monday u.s national security advisor
robert o'brien added to speculation
telling the global security forum hosted
in part by qatar
that an airbridge may be on the table
allowing qatar airways to fly over saudi
and bahraini airspace
so we'd like to get that rift solved
making sure that cutter air had
was it the cutter was able to fly over
saudi airspace or bahraini airspace
is is an important first step in solving
that rift
i'd like to see that get done before you
know if we end up leaving office
qatar's foreign minister says the
blockade which has dragged into a fourth
year
has no winner everyone is losing
we are hopeful that this uh
end you know at any moment and
what what we need right now is to have a
serious engagement in a good faith
with other countries and this is what
qatar is prepared to do
the emiratis and saudis accuse qatar of
supporting
terrorism which they say to anybody who
talks to anybody in the muslim
brotherhood or allows free elections to
take place or talks to
iran and the saudis and the muratis
really have
discredited themselves quite a bit and
it's surprising that they haven't found
a face-saving way
to end this blockade but let's hope this
this may be it
the uae may be a spoiler for any
proposed agreement
as o'brien was speaking of a resolution
to the gulf crisis being a priority for
the trump administration
the uae's ambassador to washington was
saying otherwise
with the katari rift i don't think it's
going to get resolved anytime soon
it's it's a small problem it's not
really being addressed
it's not not on anyone's you know
priority list right now
but the uae and other blockading
countries are under pressure
the us thinks better relations between
the gulf countries will help its policy
of isolating iran
and they face accusations by a u.n
special rapporteur
that the measures imposed on qatar are a
violation of fundamental rights
aimed at limiting freedom of expression
movement and trade
andrew chappelle al jazeera